we took a long strange trip into the
world of stephen kingler stephen king
sequels and we found the very best and
the very worst oddly while there have
been sequels to stephen king novels on
several occasions
his short stories are the ones that most
often get made into franchises
sometimes they come back a tale from
king's night shift collection
has spawned three different loosely
related films since it was first
published
but the second one has proven to be the
most interesting
that's cool i like that like the first
film
sometimes i come back again it's the
story of a man facing demonic forces
tied to a tragic event in his past
in this case the death of his sister
when the young thugs responsible for her
killing managed to
well come back from hell they take the
form of demonic tormentors who are
determined to finish what they started
i'm not gonna let that happen
would you i'm a tough guy now
i'm terrified why were the first
sometimes a comeback film certainly
leans heavily
into the demonic imagery near the end
the sequel goes all out with it
until the climax is just dripping with
over-the-top ritualistic violence
it's a film that traffics in quite a few
horror cliches and it's not exactly
a classic but sometimes they come back
against willingness to just go full tilt
with its monsters
makes it an extremely watchable film
anchored by the scenery chewing madness
of alexis arquette
it's honestly a bit of a minor miracle
that sometimes i come back
manage to spawn one pretty entertaining
sequel but sometimes i come back
again the problem is that the very
presence of a part 2 and its relative
success
meant that another sequel was possible
sadly part 3 didn't work out nearly
as well
like the previous films sometimes they
come back for more follows a group of
ordinary people
as they struggle against demonic forces
that have risen up from the netherworld
to kill
but this time the action takes place at
a mining installation in antarctica the
goal might have been to evoke the
claustrophobic nature of films like john
carpenter's the thing but the end result
is something bland and cold
with barely any of the wild demonic
energy that the first sequel brought to
things
though there are attempts to broaden the
mythology that's all hampered by a
lackluster script
and a low budget by the time the actual
monsters arrive there's not a lot to get
excited about
pet cemetery is quite famously the story
stephen king was worried might be too
unpleasant to publish
when it finally was director mary
lambert adapted it into one of the most
famous and frightening king films
then lambert decided to take things one
step further with a sequel
without king's involvement because of
the rather tragic ending of the first
film
pet cemetery 2 follows a completely
different family
who's just moved to ludlow maine and
they're grappling with their own family
tragedy what sets the film apart
aside from the entirely new cast of
characters is lambert's willingness to
lean in as far as possible to the
unpleasant gory aspects of the heart of
the story
no brain no pain
[Music]
this time around the chief evil zombie
character takes the form of a local
sheriff
while a dead dog takes the place of a
dead cat and a dead mother replaces a
dead son
it wasn't falls with a similar rhythm to
the original bed cemetery
but while the first film is an emotional
gut punch pet cemetery 2 is all guts
that ultimately means it's inferior to
the original film but it's still packed
with enough black comedy and slick
visual effects to make it a must see for
completis
as well as people who wanted pet
cemetery to be even darker
creep show 3 is rooted in a good idea
after all the whole concept behind
creepshow is an anthology of horror
stories that are only loosely linked
so provided you keep up the tone of the
original you can theoretically do
whatever you want
we know this now because shutter has
managed to produce a well-received creep
show tv series
that preserves both the tone and the
anthology format of the first movie
sadly this isn't the case with creep
show 3 a film made without the
involvement of original creators stephen
king and george a romero and one that
retains very little of the darkly comic
charm
that came from the first two films
once again we're presented with a series
of loosely linked stories that are meant
to convey a certain kind of impish
humorously terrifying style
but the scares don't land and the
attempt at humor just comes off as mean
spirited
horror anthologies can provide a great
platform for filmmakers to tell shorter
form scary stories on their way to
something bigger
but this film is a poor use of the creep
show name
sequels to horror classics that are set
years later and follow a new generation
of characters are common
but they're most likely to happen with
franchises carrie director brian d
palmer's adaptation of stephen king's
debut novel
didn't intentionally try to start a
franchise but it's a film which
spoilers almost everyone involved dies
leaving little room for sequels
and yet the rage carrie 2 did try to
make one happen more than 20 years later
did it actually work
well while the film is dripping with
late 90s horror cliches from the font
used in the credits to the super dated
soundtrack
as well as the random cuts to black and
white interspersed throughout the movie
it actually does manage to find its own
way
it's the story of rachel lang carrie
white's long lost half sister
who has the same telekinetic ability but
a bit less of the social awkwardness
what are you saying i have i'm saying
you're not crazy
and it's not the devil it's a trait
rachel you've inherited
in the wake of her best friend's death
rachel finds herself diving deeper
into an exploitative and cruel high
school subculture
and it awakens something in her that
she's been struggling to embrace
it's not the instant classic that carrie
was but the rage does manage to do some
rather inventive things with its own
spill on telekinetic horror
in particular the climatic sequence is
kind of stunning
and there is not exactly a time this
film the movie has a certain sense of
wit about the time and place it's coming
from
it's a film that manages to do something
interesting with a concept that
shouldn't have worked in the first place
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one